alexandria ocasio-cortez says referring
to migrants coming to the u.s
as a surge is a white supremacist
dog whistle the lady who claimed that
donald trump was putting kids in cages
and concentration camps has finally
come out and get made a statement we
were all waiting for it
because you know when project veritas
put out that video of the photo the
photos and the videos of what was going
on in these in these migrant detention
facilities
for kids james o'keefe was like where
are you at aoc you know you went down
and you you weeped
when donald trump had these these these
facilities where you know
there you go okay yeah i actually was
thinking that too you you went down
and you you cried where are you now well
fear not friends she did an instagram
video where she said
that there's no micro crisis how
dare you it's a imperialism crisis
and then she said and gut check anybody
who says surge is trying to frame it
militaristically because these these
children are not insurgents
they're not invaders they're children
she confused the word surge which means
a sudden increase
with the word insurgent which which is
like a military conflict so she's that
stupid dude well i gotta give her some
crap
because that emology is actually the
same is it really yes yeah so
surge comes from why i looked it up
because she said a lot of people were
mocking her and i was like instead of me
coming out
and just saying something you do your
research today i looked up the
the etymology surge comes from a latino
it's like it's like sugar or i can't
pronounce it
and it means a sudden rush or flow and
insurgent comes from
to surge referencing an individual who
breaks through so they're the same root
word a
massive outpouring so insurgent was a
reference to people storming the gates
or something like that
insurgents they're surging through but
that's not the point
it is not white supremacy when when nbc
said there was a surge at the border
that's insane and it's not and it's not
indicating that they're insurgents
either
right they're different words let's go
exactly they might have to say the same
route and i see what she was trying to
switch on a rap or something and like be
clever with their language but this is
just the level of politics we get in
this country
you get you know i i i facetiously said
she had bad parents i don't
i can't i don't know what her parents
are like i don't know who her parents
are shameful
but i will say i think her mom's pretty
cool have you seen her
she raised the congresswoman so i know
i've never seen her i don't know that's
a good
she speaks highly of her i don't know if
it's as if because of any single people
becoming a freshman congressman is some
level of achievement in america bro
[Laughter]
come on aoc
is a political elite masquerading as
someone working class
and that's why she loves it when
conservatives are like you're a
bartender
she that she then turns around to all of
the working-class people goes
now they're making fun of me for being
just like you
don't do that she's not just a bartender
she's a political establishment elite
she was on the board of one of those
super pacs to get these people elected
she knows what she's doing she's great
at it and she is a duplicitous
manipulator
who will scream concentration camp under
donald trump and then when joe biden ups
the ante
and has more children detained she goes
there's no migrant crisis
when aoc was a bartender if i walked up
to the bar
six foot four handsome smiled at her
dropped the 20 in advance as a tip
you think she gave me better service
after that than the short little guy who
looked dirty yeah and who didn't tip
very well yeah
damn right she would have she wants that
20. g-d-a-o
she's there for money that's why she was
working yeah in it for the
job yeah for sure listen that's why you
put it ahead when you go tip ahead
always tip ahead guys she's not working
class
she was barely talking class
she's not working class and she's also
not an educated class so what is she
no she went to college political class
yeah educated class
absolutely sorry i meant smart that's
not mutually exclusive with working
class
she's intense doesn't necessarily have a
lot of common sense i mean
it is a migrant crisis and it is a level
of classical superiority
there is a there is a supremacy issue
going on with what does that mean the
military industrial complex the banking
elite
what does that have to do with people
coming to the border and specifically
telling abc and nbc
joe biden is giving us this opportunity
and we'll get a better deal if we come
now
um that there that there is still a
crisis of people trying to get to the
united states illegally
and because it is and there is a
supremacy issue on earth
it's like a class issue so she's right
it doesn't have to be that there's not
one now there's the other
or there's not that one now it's back to
the first one it's both dude
there's that's that's absolutely besides
the point aoc
said trump was putting children in
concentration camps
now under joe biden she is saying there
is
no migrant crisis it's silly that's
that's not common sense
is a duplicitous manipulative
person what's this person i won't i
won't go further with the insult let's
keep it to the facts
i can't deny your lived experience
that's what she does
i hate the fact that we give her fuel by
talking about her well look man she's
going to be president one day so you
better start talking about her now stop
dude that thing is the thing about
popularity contests and policies there's
no stopping people like that
she's got unless they start banning her
off social media is the only there i
guess there is stopping people like that
by banning them off social media which
is kind of terrifying but
she's super popular and she's 24 or 5 or
something right she's my age
she's going to be 30 she's going to be
60 and still doing this
it's crazy and if she's in if she goes
more insane
uh that's very very dangerous for the
direction of our country
aoc is uh she she's one of the most
dangerous
people we have probably i'll i'll say
this and i hope all the left just take
clip clip this co
clip this video and then post it she's
probably the most dangerous person in
politics
because she's extremely divisive she's
extremely mean
she's duplicitous manipulative and for
all the things they complained about
trump
she represents very much those same
things yeah she embodies the danger of
populism
that's for sure she herself maybe she'll
change tomorrow but her behavior is the
danger of populism deceptive
tell me how she's a real populist she
has
i don't know 20 60 million how many
twitter followers that has nothing to do
she's popular
and that's how she gets populism is not
being popular
it's getting it's having the crowd
follow you and getting stuff done
because the crowd is obsessed with you
that's not what it is
you're just maybe there's a technical
word for it but it comes from the word
popular
right it's a reference to supporting the
people versus supporting the elites
there's elitism and there's populism
populists say what do the people want of
me and elitists say i'm going to serve
the banking institutions in the federal
reserve
aoc is not a populist she just
masquerades as one
and then she lies and spits in people's
faces and too many people don't follow
the news
and just say wow she's great because
they get all of this she was a bartender
she was a bartender so this is this is
what i've been doing i love this the
leftists have started figuring out
what's going on and posting the videos
when i tweet my leftist opinions where i
treat my my more conservative opinions
what happens is if i if i tweet tax the
rich you know what happens
conservatives don't retweet that
leftists retweet that
you're hilarious on twitter then all of
them are nervous
all of the left they see these this
retweet going viral in their bubble of
tim paul saying tax the rich and they're
like wow
timpool is based and then i'll say
something like
universal gun ownership defend 2a and
conservatives go crazy with that they're
like wow tim
he's becoming so pro-tuning and
libertarian and so based
and what happens is what people need to
understand about twitter and social
media
is that the left and the right bubbles
do not overlap so if i tweet something
the write doesn't like the left goes
nuts with it and they support it
and everybody's in the right legs the
right goes now with it and supports that
this is this is the nature of of social
media
aoc understands these principles she
manipulates them
she knows that if she says donald trump
is putting kids in concentration camps
the left will throw it to the wind and
it'll go crazy she also knows that if
joe biden is president and she tweets
there's no migrant crisis or she has an
instagram
the left will take it and throw it in
the air and go crazy not the same
leftists
but enough of them that what ends up
happening is regular democrat types
only see her supporting joe biden
and leftists who are for open borders
only see her criticizing donald trump
they don't see the overlap she exploits
this for power
it's great it's brilliant she's really
good at in fact one of the best but
she's also extremely divisive
and says the guy who's doing exactly the
same thing but i'm not i'm not
no i'm i'm tweeting my opinions i know
it's also i believe you're being
slightly performative and provocative
with that there's a big difference
to where if i tweeted something like ban
all guns and then tweeted
guns for everyone i'm not doing that i'm
tweeting things like
trans people should be armed to the
teeth and social the black panthers did
you say like ban all rich people or
something the other day i said i said
uh uh arrest arrest everyone make being
rich illegal yeah
uh those are jokes okay that's that's
different
right the point i'm making is i'm
mocking what aoc does that's the point
yes
to prove a point about the duplicitous
nature of these politicians
that i can tweet something absolutely
absurd arrest rich people
yeah but people will take that seriously
you gotta be careful if it's in text i
don't care
well that's that's ridiculous if you if
you don't the point is
they won't go to my profile and read my
tweets where i then
i said make poverty illegal make being
rich illegal arrest everyone
now here's what happens they just see
the one that gets retweeted into their
point and then when the left caught wind
of it and started saying look what he's
doing i was like hey you finally
investigated to figure out what the full
picture was supposed to be
instead of clipping things out of
context to grift on twitter
twitter is is the grift factory they
accuse everyone else of being grifters
but they come to this show
and they take a one-minute clip and they
say look what tim poole said and they
omit the other 50 minutes
and then all these people only get that
particular clip filtered to them
and so when i posted an m16 and a trans
flag the leftists are like what's
happened to tim poole
nothing we quite literally talk about
why everyone should own guns including
trans people and the black panthers
you just don't watch the show so i'm
sick and tired
of this of this manipulation game where
people take things out of context to
feed red meat to particular bases on
social media
and it's literally what aoc does when
she panders to the establishment left
and then she panders the progressives
she does not represent
any one of them she wants power
soccer yeah shocker and
i just laugh when you said that people
don't watch the other 50 minutes of the
show
and or by the way consult the entire
decade-long
body of work right so you can't right
that's the problem is you have to
cherry-pick people
so when i try and understand them i
tweeted uh
tax hollywood millionaires and
billionaires at 90 percent
and then conservatives all started
laughing and retweeting it because it's
funny because who likes hollywood
and the leftist started retweeting and
sharing it because they were like yeah
all right tax the rich we'll start we'll
start there
and everyone like hey we agree at this
point okay so we can start here and then
start to figure out who want to text
i'll tell you what i don't get though
i'm i i don't quite understand why
they're why the libertarians and the
conservatives are so concerned about
you know jeff bezos's billions of
dollars
like i understand a wealth tax makes no
sense and won't work i understand that
we don't want the government to have
power those arguments i get
but from that point on it's kind of like
okay i got no problem if we strip the
power away from the ultra wealthy and
it's funny because i tweeted this
and these leftists who just want to hate
me they're like tim but what about you
you'll be taxed as well i'm like okay
like tax bernie sanders i'll stand in
line with him
i don't care i don't like the idea that
these people have disproportionate power
and that a working-class dad who's got
three kids a working-class dad with
three kids who's making 70k 80k a year
has no say in his government because tom
steyer can
flood his entire state with 500 million
dollars
and then get guns banned another guy
can't defend himself i don't like that
and we need solutions to that i don't
know what the solution is but i'm just
like whatever tax the rich people like
tom steyer michael bloomberg shouldn't
be allowed to do what they did in this
past election
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you